Faith.
This is the best, for
all the wrong reasons.
[laughs]
Hi, my name is Charlie Santore.
I'm the owner of Santore
and Son Lock and Safe.
I'm a safe technician,
meaning safecracker,
in Southern California.
Today we're going to look at some clips
on safecracking in films,
and we'll tell you
whether they're credible
or whether they're garbage.
[safe clicking]
The clicking dial that
Hollywood loves so much.
They typically have a
bearing surface on it.
It's usually very, very smooth.
If it was properly installed,
it shouldn't be clicking.
There's, like, one or two models
of a junky safe that
you can get at Staples
where the dial clicks.
It's not really a real thing.
The sort of dialing sequence
that she would be doing
in order to do so is not
how she's dialing here.
She's actually working backwards
to how we typically would.
The principle of it is that
wheels are being searched for low spots.
And what that involves
is parking certain wheels
and moving other wheels.
And there's a certain repetitive sequence
to doing that by people
that know how to do this.
And she's not doing this here.
Come on, Charlie.
You can do this.
There's a difference between
people burglarizing things
and people opening things
the way that we open them
to put them back in service.
They're not going to be sitting around
trying to manipulate a safe open.
They would drill it open.
Even opening a safe like this,
even if you're drilling it,
is also extremely difficult.
You're not haphazardly
drilling holes in something.
You're not vandalizing something.
When we open safes,
the idea is it's like
arthroscopic surgery.
We're doing it in a
minimally invasive way.
The whole thing is a very academic study.
[clicking]
[safe clicks open]
We're supposed to believe
when that click happened,
that final click is the
fence of the lock dropping.
But here, with vault locks and safe locks,
you have to do a final turn
to pull the lock bolt back.
There's a certain amount of travel
that then opens that lock.
So she dials the combination,
here she stops at 50, the fence drops,
she's saying the safe is open,
and he turns the handle.
But the safe wouldn't be open
even if the lock was unlocked
because she didn't retract the lock bolt.
This notion of somebody creeping around
and manipulating a safe open,
it does happen and it has happened,
but nine times out of 10,
it's sledgehammers and wedges
or grinders or saws
cutting the thing open.
So, I want to be generous. It's 3.
He's taken the fingerprint
off the door with tape.
It could have been the
cleaning lady's print
that he pulled off of there.
This actually broke my head a little bit.
If you pull the print off with tape
and you turn it over and put a ring on it
and put Loctite in it,
aren't you actually making it a cast
of the inverse of the fingerprint?
This safe is serious.
Luis: How serious are we talking, Scotty?
It's a Carbondale.
Carbondale's a made-up name,
but the vault door itself,
I looked through hundreds and hundreds
of photos of vault doors,
and I'm pretty certain
that the art directors
based this off of a very
early Diebold vault door.
This is actually a real tool.
This is a StrongArm MiniRig
that's used for putting pressure
when one's drilling.
So that aspect of it
is definitely accurate.
We'll go do a quick job that
winds up being something
where you don't have your
full tool kit with you.
So there's lots of times when
we've been running around
trying to bend wires and make tools
and sort of have to come up with something
that we didn't have with us.
Supposedly he's freezing it
and it's going to expand
and crack this door apart.
What they showed us was the bolt work
inside of the safe and the door pan.
There's a big door pan.
If he poured a gallon of water in there,
it would spill out the bottom
of the door pan, basically.
If by chance he froze it
and the ice expanded, I mean,
obviously water can expand.
Glaciers expand over time.
The thing about a vault door
is, in this case,
there's a thin back panel
that's like sheet metal essentially
on the back of the door.
So the idea that that's going
to expand is pure fantasy.
It would blow the back panel off
before it blew the door off.
There's nothing here.
What'd you say?
It's a suit.
I opened up a couple of safes
that were at a Blockbuster Video a while
and there was Astroglide,
condoms, and some dirty photos.
So I don't know if a manager
was having a fling with somebody,
but that was pretty unexpected.
On the more valuable side of things,
we once opened a safe
in an affluent part of Beverly Hills
that people had recently
moved into a home.
The former owner was gone.
There were Bulgari
necklaces, Cartier necklaces,
Krugerrands, GIA certificates.
I mean, I can only imagine that it
must have been a mid-
to high-six-figure lick.
But I think that people get traumatized
when there's that much left
because they're not expecting
to have a moral conflict, sort of.
You know, "It's technically mine,
but this obviously meant a great deal
to whoever it was that
was living here before."
It's nonsense, but the MiniRig is real.
So I'm going to give it a 3.
Scott: How would you
like to make 250 grand
for one day's work?
Oh, my God.
There are certainly a lot of safes
that are known among people
who do this kind of work
that are very, very difficult to open.
Very well-guarded locks.
So, yeah, there is some truth to that.
But of the world's living locksmiths,
do I represent your greatest
chance of opening it?
I can, with humility,
say yes.
The biggest myth I think
is that there's some boffin
or there's some maven
who has the, you know,
magic touch to get the thing open.
The four locks?
You know what that is?
Scott: No.
Dieter: No, of course not.
It's a rotating randomization mechanism.
If you mess it up again, it locks forever.
You understand? Forever.
Las Vegas is overrun with zombies.
The idea that they're
going to bring some genius
to come and manipulate open four locks
on a vault door is ridiculous.
They would just bring a coring crew.
They'd bring coring stuff,
and they're bore a hole
in the side of the vault
and get it open.
How long will it take you to open it?
30 minutes.
The idea that somebody
would manipulate open
four vault locks in half
an hour is pure fantasy.
[lock clicking]
He's supposedly manipulating this open.
He's not even looking at the dial,
which is where he would be
looking for the indications
that he would use to manipulate it open.
And there's also some hieroglyphs
or some scrawling that he wrote on
or he drew on the front of the door
that really has nothing to do with
what he would be doing in
order to get this open.
The doors are always heavy.
You're talking about a
multi-multi-ton door.
There are compression systems
that'd have spinning wheels.
Not all vault doors have those.
Some have handles.
According to him, this
vault has four locks on it.
When the vault door swings open,
we see that there's actually
only two vault locks
on the back of the door
and a time lock with five movements.
I've never seen a five-movement time lock.
I'm going to give it a 2
as far as the realism goes.
He's using an autodialer.
There are such tools.
I mean, they don't look like
a vacuum cleaner hooked
up to a Xerox machine.
It's smaller, it's portable.
You hook it up and it runs through,
it parks wheels, and it runs
through a dialing sequence.
The advantage is on some safes
that have glass relockers in them
or that might be problematic to drill
or some people don't
have the necessary tools
to open some of those safes.
He's reading the paper at one point
and he's sitting around.
And that's, I mean,
that's pretty accurate.
It's not an instantaneous process.
The much earlier versions
sometimes could take anywhere
from, like, I think 10 to
30 hours to open a safe.
The newer ones are faster,
and if one of the numbers is known,
then it's even infinitely faster.
A lot of times people set them up
in their shop and they go off for the day
and they come back the following day.
We don't use an autodialer.
People who are able to manipulate well
can usually open something in
30 minutes, 45 minutes.
The weird and wonderful thing now
is a tape measurer.
A tape measurer is very, very useful.
You know, they're telling kids that
they don't have to learn math
and that there's no right answers to math.
You can't do this job without being able
to read a tape measurer, that's for sure.
But no, as far as high-tech tools go,
there's lots of different
picks for certain key locks.
People have to think of their safes
and their vault doors as
the last line of defense.
You should have alarms,
you should have cameras.
Make sure there's no outlets
around in close proximity.
If it's a smaller safe,
if you can stick it in a horrible position
where it's hard to get to,
sometimes under cabinetry,
under furniture.
And, truthfully, the best safe is one
that no one knows is even there.
So that's why in-floor
safes are very popular.
Wall safe, someone can just
cut it out of the studs
if they know that it's there.
About a 4 or 5, 'cause
there are autodialers.
Guard: My shoes are melting!
Aah!
The one element of this that is correct
is that oftentimes
when there's a vault lockout,
a lot of vaults can be
opened from the inside,
and there's a way to
open the door sometimes.
But there's not another lock on the inside
that somebody would have to crack.
Hey!
Hey, that's my hearing aid!
As far as a listening device goes,
people do use amps.
It usually has a little
magnet on it, so it sticks.
Or if it's a stainless thing
that it won't stick to,
you can hold it there, tape it in place,
and it's got a little pot on it
that the level turns up.
And when you're dealing with a metal door,
the sound actually
travels very, very well.
Just to be generous, we'll say 3.
The main issue is if he
was using a cutting torch
to cut that square,
the gear that's right in back of there
that supposedly he's moving
would probably have been damaged,
as well as any sort of
electrical components.
There's lots of metal that comes off.
As far as burglary goes,
people use torches often.
And even earlier on,
safe technicians used to
use torches and lances
because there's certain metals
that are very, very hard to drill.
Typically, vault locks
are a little bigger.
Safe locks are a little smaller,
but they all work on the same principle,
that there's a blocking point.
And so that aspect of
it, that something small
is actually keeping
something large locked,
that aspect of it is very true.
A lot of vault doors use yokes.
There's pivoting yokes,
but it's still a lock
bolt attacked to a lock.
I would say, like, a 3.5.
I will say that there are certain locks
that do have a stepper motor in them
that, to open them sometimes
when they're being drilled,
there's a gear that gets
turned a certain way.
The only real issue that I probably have
is they're using pneumatic drills.
I doubt somebody would
use pneumatic lines.
This comes closest to what we do
on a regular basis.
They've drilled into the
safe before they hit glass.
Normally the glass would
be much, much closer
to the back of the door,
so you wouldn't have this
much working space in there.
There's 2, 2 1/2, 3
inches of working space.
You see them stick a borescope up.
They find the cable loop.
She sticks a wire in.
She lassos the cable.
The only real issue
is that they're going to
tie this off to a chair
with people sitting on it.
That's nonsense. That's not necessary.
All they'd have to do is
take vice grips probably
and clamp them right at the door,
and that cable isn't going anywhere.
It's a spring-loaded thing.
We have to assume that
she had intimate knowledge
of what kind of safe it was.
Somebody leaked the information to her.
Nine times out of 10,
somebody knows that there
was a safe somewhere,
and it's not necessarily the person
who knew that it was
there, but a lot of times,
they sell the information
to somebody else,
they pass it on to somebody else,
like Paul Rudd coming into your house
with an air mattress and Freon
and a jug of water to
blow your vault door off.
It's, like, probably a 9 or a 9.5
as far as that goes.
It's one of the best
that we've seen so far.
This is the heist that happened
at 88-90 Hatton Garden,
where a bunch of geriatric ex-gangsters
cored the vault, and they breached it,
and they cleaned out
I think 70-plus boxes.
When this story broke,
I was obsessed with it.
I think they're even using the exact gear
that was actually used
to get into the vault.
And my understanding is
it happened over a three-day weekend.
They wound up using a coring rig.
They cored overlapping holes.
When they realized that they
had to get a pneumatic pump,
they built a brace and they
put a pneumatic pump in
in order to force the
boxes away from the wall.
The boxes obviously inside of this vault
are not the same boxes
that were inside the
actual Hatton Garden vault,
because the photos that we've seen
was a hodgepodge of different
kind of locks and boxes,
different-sized boxes.
In this one, they're much more uniform.
This really, I mean, is, like, probably,
like, a 9.5 or a 10 out of 10, really.
Faith.
This is the best, for
all the wrong reasons.
[laughs]
DMX, rest in peace,
but all I'll say is that
if DMX shows up at your house
with a bazooka to open your vault,
your problem's getting out of hand.
It's so entertainingly stupid.
We have to look at this.
We're on the fourth
floor of a bank building.
They're shooting a bazooka through a wall.
I mean, it's,
we're going to give it a 3.
Not based on anything technical at all.
The tool that James Caan is using is real.
The drill bit that James
Caan is using in there
is about this big, OK?
And the kind of bit that we typically use
to drill open a safe if
we're scoping something
is about this big.
But if you look at the proximity
of how the wheels sit
to where that dial is
and the way the light is
shining on the wheels,
my sense is that this is
a little bit of a mock-up.
There are many, many safes, older safes
that utilize a punching
technique like that.
In this situation, I don't believe
that that's what would
have been necessary.
I mean, especially with the hole that big.
The gates could have been dialed up.
But, again, I think that
we're coming up against
trying to have authentic realism
and trying to maintain a
certain amount of secrecy
and trying to give the
audience a little taste
of what's actually real.
I would have to give this,
like, a 8.5, probably.
On a slow year, we open
probably 300-plus safes.
On a busy year, probably closer to 500.
I get to maybe exercise
that part of my shadow,
and I get to help people in the process.
So, I mean, I can't think
of a thing I'd rather do.
Thank you very much for watching.
If you liked what you saw,
click on the link above.